watch the official first trailer
for red f30 carnage at the 55th super
bowl's halftime show
on the 7th of february on cbs
only in theaters this june rated r
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel
and sometimes things that are marvel and
not in the marvel cinematic universe
yes of course we are talking about venom
to let there be carnage
as you just saw there is a new teaser
going around
online right now for venom let there be
carnage stating
that the official trailer is going to be
showing at the super bowl
now let me just be very upfront right
now i do not know if this is real or not
it certainly seems real and marvel is in
the business of
showing trailers during the super bowl
but venom is marvel
and sony now of course sony has shown
trailers at the super bowl as well
before and since sony and marvel have
both
shown trailers during the super bowl it
would make sense that they would
premiere the venom let there be carnage
trailer
during the super bowl now this was
posted by the twitter account venom
movie news and they've been accurate
about some things concerning venom let
there be carnage in the past but again i
still don't know if this
is real there's really no way to tell
because it is something that sony and
marvel would do
showing a trailer during the super bowl
but who knows that voice
kind of sounds fake it could be real but
it could also be fake and the ad is very
specific
about them showing the trailer during
the halftime show for the super bowl
typically when marvel announces a
trailer for something they don't say
when it's specifically going to be
during the super bowl they just say
during the super bowl also keep in mind
this short video is the exact tease that
we got before when they release the
title
it's exactly the same and then they just
showed the ad for the super bowl after
again there's really no way of
confirming whether or not this
is real and i'm very cautious to say
that it is real after the last time we
got that fake post from andy circus
stating that the trailer was coming when
it didn't
there's a lot of evidence that suggests
that this could be real but i would take
that with a grain of salt in case it's
not
but hopefully we will be getting a venom
leatherby carnage trailer
during the super bowl it would make a
lot of sense considering the fact that
when the super
bowl airs there's only going to be about
four months more
until venom let there be carnage comes
out so that's definitely when they
should
release a teaser for it they should have
actually released it before
four months in advance isn't that much
time but the
super bowl is certainly a great place to
do it so fingers crossed that it
actually comes and that this
is real and hopefully this ad will air
on tv pretty soon and we'll know for
sure
and either way it's nice to finally get
some venom 2
news it's been quiet for a very long
time so let me know how excited you are
about venom
let there be carnage in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you can stay up
to date on everything happening
with venom let there be carnage for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof